what's going on reject nation okay so we
got some marvel trailers to be covering
so we're gonna start with the falcon and
winter soldier
and then the next one going up will be
one division but all right exclusive
first look for falcon and winter soldier
finally get a good look at this bad boy
let's see what's in store and then loki
i think is going to be coming out too
it's probably already out by the time
this is uploaded
let's just get into it shall we
oh legacy of that shield is
complicated
you're finally getting footage like real
footage
damn wow
that's the lighting alone people need
something to get behind
i saw the name wilson i think his own
company back there
i love the look of the wings
so what's our plan
oh yeah
do i love his outfit so no plan
right
not bad wow
wow
dude look at this look at him go
falcon's ever been cooler
gear's turning oh they're malfunctioning
they're on fire
oh buddy oh grappling
all right guys there's so much out so we
got to keep these thoughts quick but
right now
i think this looks exactly like what
i've been hoping it would look like this
really cool
action driven pulse pounding almost like
fugitive yet buddy cop type of vibe
going on here i mean at the beginning it
looks like that
sam is over at like the captain america
uh
museum memorial that it was that we've
seen before i saw in the background it's
like wilson seafood or something like
that so i imagine that
at the beginning of this series hiding
out in his family home and then
i don't know if he's just like trying to
get off the grid in some way because
after the events of the sokovia accords
and the
after the events of the blip that it
seems like it's still following in that
direction where
spider-man far from home kind of had a
humorous approach to the post events of
the blip
this looks like it's taking the very
serious version
of the post events of the blip like the
gritty real world
state yeah it's gonna be like what rebel
factions might arise in light of that
like it looks like it's gonna have all
the super scope but also much more of a
gritty
sort of tangible just conflict exactly
and i love the suits that they have they
look so so
[ __ ] cool you know especially
especially sam's man this falcon suit
looks so much cooler
oh yeah they punched that thing up that
seems like what a lot of it is they're
gonna be working together
and honoring uh the legacy of captain
america because i see in that football
stadium which i believe is that john
walker super patriot moment that we've
seen
before flashed on screen i'm surprised
we didn't get any wyatt russell here in
the trailer but maybe he is and
we just didn't catch it the vibe that
i'm sort of getting is that post blip
there's probably some people who are
taking advantage of the kind of way the
crisis of the world
has been it looks like they're going to
be dealing with the missing presence of
captain america and meanwhile the
government has their own
john walker super patriot thing going on
i imagine that there's a lot of this
weird
military type of corruption deal so
while they're being future there's they
have to be heroes you're just getting
all that like pulse pounding vibe i
don't know what this symbol the the
mask symbol that they all have on is
that base paint on i don't know what
that is
feel free if you're more familiar with
it than i am
let us know i'm welcoming it all right
let us know but as it stands this looks
very promising and it's gonna look this
really feels like it should be a movie
absolutely i was flashing back to the
first iron man during all those desert
fight scenes and whatnot and hey i mean
if that's what they're bringing to their
disney plus caliber like i'm excited i
mean the aerial shots look spectacular
here
the sequences look that easily could
have been the sequence of the canyon
that easily could have been something
that
just looks terrible and like an awful
cgi experiment but
it looks like a cool blend of stunt work
and cgi all meshed into
one and another thing that i found kind
of interesting about it was that the
trailer really made it feel more like
bucky is supporting character here which
does make sense of the fact that it's
falcon and the winter soldier and also
the shield was ultimately handed off to
sam
to make it be more of sam's show with
bucky being the main supporting
character i also
i'm kind of under the impression bucky
might steal the show every once in a
while
you know he's got some underdog statuses
true true or come and so i'm sure
they'll play into some of that too
all right guys well we gotta move on got
a couple of other trailers to cover too
including bad batch i'll see you guys in
a few minutes